I say the false alarm is one where your alarm goes off, so positive for
burglary, but there isn't a burglary.
So in the true world the event is negative, but your system says positive.
So this is where the check mark should go and you can see a bit of an asymmetry.
You can see that you might care about negative events that give you
a positive alarm differently from positive events that are being missed.
And just to give you kind of a little bit of look ahead,
often by changing parameters you can move this curve in either direction.
And if you believe that a false alarm, which is the police come to
your house checking for burglary, is a different price point from a missed event
like someone robbing you of all your belongings without police even noticing,
then you might want to reshift this line up and down.